the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this afternoon by by welcoming our
virtual audience the audience that's
looking at this lecture on MIT
OpenCourseWare some of you attentive
viewers may notice what the students
here would not notice that seven years
have elapsed there's a new podium some
of you may have gotten that and a much
older professor I hope that our
completion of these lectures seven years
later will not will not result in a in a
in a reduced or less energetic
performance I'll do my best
we come now to the end of our Earl of
art of our first segment in the course
on silent film and I thought it would be
helpful to use today's lecture in part
to create some perspectives on both the
silent film the idea of the silent film
not just the particular films we've
looked at but more generally the
phenomenon of silent film the whole the
whole phenomenon and some perspectives
that will also help us look forward to
what will follow to the to the sound
films that will follow this week I'd
like in in a certain way to do this by
complicating the an idea I've already
suggested to you about the the notion of
the film as a cultural form what does it
actually mean to say that a film is a
cultural form what in a concrete sense
does this phrase signify well one answer
I think I can offer by drawing on your
own experience my guess is that all of
you have watched older films films from
20 or 30 or 40 years ago and immediately
been struck as soon as you began to
watch the film by certain kind
of differences that the original
filmmakers would have been oblivious to
and I'm talking about things like the
hairdos of people the clothing that they
wear the way automobiles look or even a
world in which there are no automobiles
the physical environment that is shown
one of the things that this reminds us
of is that that films always even the
most surreal and imaginative and science
fiction films always inevitably in some
deep way in some essential ways reflect
the society from which they come they
may reflect more than that and they may
be influenced by other factors as well
but they are expressions of the culture
that gave rise to them in certain really
essential ways and one of the things
this means among other significance one
of the most interesting aspects of this
recognition is the fact that films get
richer over time they become artifacts
of immense anthropological interest even
if they're terrible films because they
show us what the world of 50 or 25 or 30
years ago actually looks like and how
people walked and how people calm their
air and what kind of makeup they were
all of the things that in many of the
things which in many respects the people
making the original film would simply
have taken for granted as part of the
reality they were trying to dramatize so
one way of thinking about film as a
cultural form is to recognize that as
films grow older they equip meaning they
become more interesting they become they
become richer and and the Kuril a or
corollary implication of this idea that
films are that films that films become
richer is that is that the meaning of
the of any individual artifact cultural
artifact especially cultural artifacts
as complex as films are is always in
process that the meaning is never fully
fixed or finished but new significance
and new possibilities new meanings
emerge from these texts with the passage
of time as if the texts themselves
undergo a kind of transformation one
final point about this just to sort of
tweak your broader understanding of
these kinds of questions one of the
kinds of curve
decisions that occurs with particular
artifacts as they sometimes move or make
a kind of transition from being
recognized as merely ordinary and
uninteresting parts of the society from
which they go from which they grow from
which they emerge simply ordinary
routine aspects of the experience of
society later ages may may value these
routine objects as profoundly valuable
works of art and in a certain sense one
could say that the films the film in the
United States underwent a transition of
that kind that at a certain point in the
history of our understanding of movies
American culture began to recognize that
movies were actually works of art that
they but deserved comparison with novels
in place this is plays and poems and so
forth probably an idea that all of you
folks take for granted your generation
probably many of the members of your
generation admire movie directors more
than they do novelists and poets a
radical mistake it seems to me but
that's my literary bias showing through
I certainly admire great directors
certainly as much as I do good novelists
but the fact is that this is really not
the kid this this recognition of the
film as an artistic object as I've
suggested earlier in the course is not
some fixed or stable identity that the
film has had from the beginning it's an
identity that the film has garnered that
the film has that has been laid on the
film later as cultural changes have
occurred and there's other forms of
expression have emerged that have put
the film in a kind of different position
hierarchically from from other kinds of
from other kinds of imaginative
expressions and as I've already
suggested many times in this course
we'll come back to this principle
because it's such a central historical
fact about the nature the content of
American movies especially it's the
advent of television that is partly
responsible for the transformation
although it takes some time for the
transformation in American attitudes
toward what movies are because
television became the throwaway item the
routine item the thing Americans
experienced every day and the
consequence of that was to change
our understanding of what the film was
now of course the Europeans had an
insight like this long before the
Americans did and that's something I'll
talk about in a bit later today and also
at other times in our course so that's
one way of thinking about the what it
means to say that a film is a cultural
form it means that it's an unstable in
the sense that its meanings are not
fixed and the way in which a culture
categorizes and understands a particular
artifact is also something that's
unstable that undergoes change over time
but there are other ways to think about
this problem of film as a cultural
formation as an expression of society
and I want to tease out some of those
meanings for you as well one of them is
kind of one way to come at this problem
is is to think of a kind of tension or
or even contention between our
recognition that film is a global form
that is to say that certain at because
the movies are watched across national
boundaries movies that are made in the
United States can influence movies that
are made in Europe and vice versa
so there's what also in one sense the
film especially after film got going
within the first ten years of its life
it had become a international phenomenon
and American films were watched in
Europe and European films influenced
influenced American directors even at
very early stages so that we began to
get certain kinds of films that
certainly appealed across national
boundaries and so that there is a kind
of global dimension to what film might
be um and there's another way of
thinking about what it means to talk
about film as a global food as a global
phenomenon not as a merely national
expression and that has to do
specifically with the way in which
particular directors improve and and
films in particular societies can
influence world cinema and from the very
earliest days of cinema as I suggested
this has been a reality as David cooks
history of narrative film informs you
and I hope you'll read the assigned
chapters on Russian film closely because
I can only skim these topics in my
lecture what you'll discover among other
things is that the great American
director DW Griffith had a profound
impact on Russian films and and that in
fact at a certain point in the history
of Russian films there was a workshop
run by a man named Kuleshov who actually
took DW Griffith's movies and
disassembled them shot by shot and
studied the editing rhythms in his in
his workshop and this had a profound
impact on not only on Russian cinema but
but the but Griffiths practices had a
profound impact on virtually all
filmmakers and and there's a kind of
reverse influence because certain
Russian directors Eisenstein especially
but also Dziga Vertov had profound in
their work had a profound impact on the
films from Western Europe and from the
United States so it's a two-way process
it's too simple to say that that
particular films are only an expression
of French culture are only an expression
of Russian culture or only an expression
of American culture
they are also global phenomena and they
were global phenomena from almost the
earliest stages so it's important to
recognize this tension or this balance
there are dimensions of film that reach
across national boundaries and as we've
already suggested one of the
explanations for the success of American
movies in the United States was in part
a function of the fact that they did not
require language in nearly the same
degree
they were visual experiences and an
immigrant population coming into the
large cities of the United States at the
turn of the century was one of the
primary factors that helps to explain
the phenomenal quick growth of the
movies from a novelty into a profound
embedded cultural experience right so it
is a global phenomenon in a certain way
it reaches across national boundaries
but there's also and we need to
acknowledge this side of the equation
too there's also a profound a really
deep of fundamental sense in which films
at least until very recently are an
expression of the individual national
cultures from which they come I say
until very recently because some of you
must be aware of the fact that a new
kind of film is being made now by which
I mean a film that seems to appeal
across all national
that doesn't seem to have a decisive
national identity at least some films
like that I think the Bollywood people
are making films like this
Americans are certainly making films
like this now and sometimes if you think
of some of the action-adventure films
that will have a cast that is drawn from
different cultures right a sort of
multi-ethnic and a multilingual cast all
of them all of them dubbed into whatever
language the film is being is being
exhibited in you'll see and examine that
what's begun to emerge now in our 21st
century world is a kind of movie that
already conceives of itself as belonging
to a kind of global culture so far I'm
not sure in these movies have have as
much artistic interest as one would like
but it's a it's a new phenomenon and the
globalizing tendencies of digital
technology are certainly encouraging new
ways to think about the the origins or
the or the or the central sources of
movies but until very recently it is
still the case that virtually every film
made in any society reflected in deep in
fundamental ways aspects of that society
and one of the reasons that this is such
an important thing to recognize is it
means that especially in cultures like
your the European societies and and
those that in the United States the
movies are a profoundly illuminating
source of cultural and social history
even if they had no artistic interest
they would be worth teaching and
studying and the fact that some of them
are luminous works of art makes teaching
of teaching them a particular a
particular pleasure a particular joy a
real vocation so if we talk about films
as a national as an as a national
expression what we're talking about here
is the extent to which the assumptions
about personal relationships and the
assumptions about the way society
operates are going to be grounded in
culturally socially specific phenomena
of socially specific practices and we're
also talking not just about the content
of movies but also about the structure
of the industries which end up providing
movies to the public and
part of what I wanted at least allude to
today in the in the lectures and
materials that we're looking at today is
to crystallize or concretize this idea
the the variations that are possible
within a within the broad universe of
the cinema so that for example the
individual and atomistic system that
developed in the United States for the
production of movies the capitalist
arrangements that developed in the
United States for the development of
movies are in many ways radically
different from the systems that were
developed in some European societies or
in the Soviet Union and there's a
particular contrast with the Soviet
Union which developed movies in a quite
in a quite different way and had a quite
different notion about them the
emergence of the movies coincides in
some degree with the turmoil in the
Soviet Union right the Russian
Revolution is what 1917 movies become
the central a central source of of
information and propaganda for the
emerging Soviet culture Lenin called
movies our greatest art form because he
understood how important they they were
in promulgating certain ideals and in
embedding those ideals in the society
and in fact they were not in Russia a
series of independent companies that
produced films there was a top-down
arrangement in which the government
controlled film make doesn't mean that
they didn't make remarkable and
interesting films but it was a different
system it was a top-down system we had
central government financing in which
the the genres of Soviet films could be
said to have had what we might call
rhetorical sources for example a
revolution story is one genre of Russian
film celebrating the heroics celebrating
the heroic struggle of the people there
were even sort of genres that we might
call building genres or creating genres
and they were about make creating a farm
or building a skyscraper right and was
the film was put in the service by the
Soviet state was put in the service
this emerging society it was understood
as a as a as a system that would
mobilize mass social forces for the
betterment of society and the the
differences that these differences in
attitudes toward the and in the ways
films are financed and and and who makes
the decisions about what films will go
forward of course has a profound impact
on the nature of those movies are our
demonstration instance today will be one
of the most famous passages from
Eisenstein's Potemkin to demonstrate
some of the in a much more concrete way
some of the implications of this
difference between American and Russian
film that I'm suggesting there were also
profound differences and I'll develop
this argument a little more fully to
this evening when we shift over to the
great German silent films that will
silent film that we're going to look at
tonight
there were profound differences between
the American and German systems of
moviemaking and attitudes toward the
making of movies and I'll elaborate on
some of those notions later later today
in the evening lecture but for the
moment then suffice it to say that that
movies that virtually all movies are
going to reveal or going to embody the
values and assumptions of the culture
from which they come that that makes
them anthropological artifacts of
profound significance and distinguishes
French film from British film from
American film in ways that continue to
be illuminating and significant but
there's certain other contrasts or or
potential tensions in this notion of
film as a cultural form that I'd also
like to develop and what or spend a
little bit more time on one of them is
this is the notion that there's a
profound even a fundamental difference
more broadly not just between French and
American cinema but between all forms of
European cinema and the American version
and this is a principle we'll talk about
more this evening but I want to allude
to it now one of the ways to crystallize
this is to remind you of something we've
already talked about briefly in the
course which is the migration of
filmmaking from the east coast of
West Coast in the early days of
filmmaking in the United States the
flight of filmmakers to California and
we've talked a little bit about why
that's a significant significant
transformation and a significant move
but perhaps the most important aspect of
this trend of this of this historical
fact the migration of the movies to the
west coast is that what this meant is
that the movies in the United States
were able to develop in a culture whose
intellectual and artistic and cultural
authorities were on the East Coast as
far away as possible from where movies
were developing in other words the
American movie is much more
fundamentally in its emergence a popular
form an honor to a form that has no
consciousness of itself as a work of art
it knows that what it's trying to do is
make money and entertain people and and
the earliest very earlier there were
some directors like DW Griffith who
recognized the artistic importance of
movies I don't mean there weren't
directors who recognize this Chaplin
surely thought of himself as making
works of art especially later in his
career but the fact is the American
movies begin on the farthest Western
verge of the society
nothing developed there right New York
is the Cultural Center Boston is a
cultural center maybe we could even say
some of the great Midwestern cities have
some kind of cultural Authority but
there's nothing on the west coast and
what that means is that all the writers
all the dramatists all the actors all
the theater actors all the poet's all
the musicians they were in the East they
lived in New York right and what there
was a kind of freedom that this imparted
to American movies and this is a very
sharp contrast with the development of
almost all forms of European cinema
because partly because there's what the
cultures are literally geographically
more limited unlike the vast expense of
the United States but also because of
the much stronger traditions in these
European societies of high culture the
much stronger respect in these in these
societies for for theater and for poetry
and for prose narrative means
in the in the European societies and
this was especially true in Germany but
it was true in some degree in every
European society including the Soviet
Union there was a sense that the movies
were emerging in the shadow of older art
forms whose greatness and grandeur
shadowed menaced this emerging form and
in a way the distinction I'm mentioning
the difference I'm mentioning accounts
both for the limitations and for the
glories of both kinds of film because if
the European film was more static and
we'll talk much more I'll give you some
examples of this tonight if the European
film was more static let's say it was
less cinematic in a way in its early
years because it thought of itself as
emerging from literature from theatre
from poetry and in fact some of them the
important early German filmmakers
especially were people who came from
theatre and they had theatrical notions
of what art was we'll talk more about
this this evening as so because that was
true the glory of the early European
cinema was its recognition that it could
be artistically powerful its sense that
it was talking about important subjects
but of course the limitations were that
it was often very boring visually that
it was serious but not a movie that it
didn't it didn't exploit the properties
of the medium nearly as quickly didn't
try to explore the unique properties of
the medium nearly as could it partly
cause it was so enthralled to inherited
ideas of artistic value and artistic
expression this isn't entirely a
disadvantage as I've said because it
also imported to European filmmakers a
sense of dignity and the importance of
their enterprise that served them well
in certain ways and made them pick
ambitious subjects and you'll see the
outcome the final outcome once the film
once the European film was liberated
into a greater cinematic freedom and
I'll show you an example or two tonight
of that it became something immensely
rich in part because it had this legacy
of high art behind it and high artistic
ambitions the United States story is
almost the opposite in the United States
there was a kind of glorious sense of
having
no responsibilities toward older art
forms there was something exuberant
experimental joyous on unembarrassed
about early American films they didn't
think of themselves as artworks and it
gave them a kind of freedom
they were also vulgar as hell they were
often they were often trivial and silly
they often had had limited artistic
ambitions but they explored the nature
of the medium in a way that became the
legacy of the movies in assert a legacy
that was communicated to other to other
societies as well
well this distinction then between
American and European cinema is
something I'll develop a little bit more
fully with examples this evening but
it's a crucial distinction it's a
crucial difference and it tells us a lot
about both forms of filmmaking there's
one final tension that I want to mention
here we'll return to it again when we
come to look at singing in the rain
later in the course which dramatizes
this subject among others there's
another kind of tension implicit in what
I've already said which is the tension
between what we might call popular
culture notions of culture that are
enjoyed by the masses by everyone as
against high culture like opera and
poetry and theatre which which only the
educated people go to right and this
tension is especially important it says
it's important in many films but it's a
it's an especially important tension in
the in American movies and one of the
things that we will come back to in
different ways as we think about these
American films is the way in which very
often American films position themselves
as the antagonists of high culture and
there are many films that actually do
that in one of the Marx Brothers some of
the Marx Brothers films systematically
dismantle the objects of high culture
there's one mark Marx Brothers film
called a Night at the Opera which takes
place in an opera and the whole set
comes crashing down the whole place the
whole place falls apart in the course of
the in the course of the film acting out
a kind of aggression against the older
art form and this is attention also that
we will see played out in some of the
films were going to be looking at a bit
later in the course so this notion of
Hollywood as
as the embodiment of a certain kind of
demoting vigor and and and populist
energy is is a it is a helpful way of
thinking about how especially in the
early years American film was somewhat
different from European film and how it
also very aggressively distinct was
happy to distinguish itself from
established art forms I want to take a
quick of what will appear to be a
digression but actually isn't I want to
talk about now about two crucial terms
that that are that will be useful in our
in our discussions of these of the
matters I've already raised in some
other matters that will come up later in
the course and and then return after
after clarifying these terms to an
example from battleship potemkin
Eisenstein's most famous film to
demonstrate something of what I mean by
by the principles of top-down
organization and and film as propaganda
that I was talking about earlier as well
as calling your attention to some of the
artistic innovations that we still
attribute to sir ji Eisenstein the two
terms I want to discuss are the terms
montage and Mies onsen their contrasting
elements of what is in all movies in a
certain way the term montage and the
term use onsen describe the most
essential features of what movies are
means onsen a term drawn from the
theater which literally it's a french
word literally means what is put or
placed in the scene right what is what
is in the scene knees onsen refers to
the single shot to what goes on within
the single continuous unedited shot of
film the single the frame of film
however long it lasts right and the mise
onsen of that of that shot is virtually
everything inside that frame in other
words how the even even how the cat
actors move in the frame is part of the
DS onsen but it's especially the meas
onsen emphasizes what is the environment
like what's the furniture like what's
the relation between the foreground the
middle ground in the background
in in in muse onsen the emphasis is on
the composition within the frame and
sometimes very great directors will
compose their frames with such subtlety
that if you freeze them they look like
paintings there they're balanced and or
or unbalanced if that's the artists
attention in in particularly artistic
and complex and complex ways so what we
can we can think of this in some sense
almost as an a as a as having a kind of
painterly equivalent in what goes on in
the scene you know within the other
great term montage which is also a
French term comes from the verb the
French verb monter which means to
assemble or to put together and a
montage means what is put together what
is edited what is what is what is what
what what is linked together so a
montage means the editing of continuous
shots in a in a sequence right so then
the montage of a film is the rhythm of
attending so all films have both
elements in them right and in fact we
need to be aware of both and when we
look at a film it's often very helpful
to ask yourself questions about the
rhythm of the editing to pay attention
to how long the shots are held to the
way the film is edited again the
Eisenstein example we're going to look
at in a minute we'll give you some
dramatic instances of why manipulating
the editing in the montage can be so so
dramatic and so signifying so it has
there's a kind of convention that has
now developed that has that the vent
that has developed and though it all
radically simplifies in some ways it's a
simplification that's immensely
instructive one way you can talk about
directors is to categorize them as
montage directors or meson send
directors these on send direct about
oversimplifying remember because there's
montage in every film so Amazon said
director can be a master of editing too
and a director that we identify as a
montage director certainly has to know
how to manipulate his muse on sin so
it's not as if one kind of director
doesn't do the other thing but what it
does try to signify what it does try to
indicate is that directors we call
montage directors are directors whose
effects
in in a central way from the way they
edit the film from the from the from the
quickness of their editing from-from the
way their editing manipulates our
controls meaning in some sense and we
therefore would think of montage
directors Eisenstein is a classic
example Hitchcock is probably the
contemporary example near contemporary
example that most of you might have in
mind in which the editing of the film
the rhythm of the the quickness with
which the shots are developed the way
the music is superimposed on the on the
on the editing rhythm to increase your
your your your emotional response to the
film what we would say is that that's
that's that's what a montage director
and embodies the work of a month so if
we say that Hitchcock is a montage
director what we mean is that some of
his mode most of his most profound
meanings come from the way in which he
edits his film come and and what a
contrast would be let's say with the
director like the director we're going
to see a few a few in a few weeks later
in the term Jean Renoir an era a
realistic director who might be called
much more fully a montage music sender
actor because he does edit is editing
rhythms are subtle but he's interested
in long takes montage directors like
short takes shots that lasts only a
short time in the in the most dramatic
segments of the segment from batting
battleship potemkin that I'm going to
show you this afternoon in a few minutes
sometimes the the edits are so brief
that they don't even last a second and a
half the average number of shots in the
film as a whole in battleship potemkin
as a whole the shots last four seconds
that's not very long in a in a you know
in a Renoir film they might last 10 15
seconds sometimes much longer than that
right that's a very long time for a shot
to be held and if a shot is held that
long it means the camera will move
character action will occur in it but
it'll still be a single shot can you see
that if you hold the shot for that time
and the camera moves like this
what is it encouraging it's encouraging
you to think about the relation between
characters and the environment it's
encouraging a kind of real
dick a response to what the film is
showing you whereas if you're looking at
a film in which the cuts occur every two
seconds you don't have time to sort of
take in what's the relation between the
actor and the furniture you are you're
disoriented inside and in fact Hitchcock
often brought his editing to a point
just below the threshold of
disorientation when Eisenstein was
theorizing about the power of editing he
was one of the first great film
theorists he talked about the way in
which you could control an audience
physiologically by manipulating montage
and it's true you can as you will know
and something that fascist societies are
fully aware of and and make and make use
of so this distinction between montage
and Nisan sin is immensely useful and is
and and and in some degree if you apply
the terms generously and tactfully you
can learn something about every film you
look at by thinking about how these
elements work in the film I want to turn
now to the arguably the one of the most
famous certainly one of the most famous
films in the history of cinema and to
way to a a particular fragment from the
film or an extended one which I think
embodies and will help clarify many of
the abstract ideas I've just been
suggesting to you let me say a word
about the film the film Battleship
Potemkin was produced in 1925 at a point
when Eisenstein was now at the height of
his power and authority and it it
commemorates a moment in the aborting an
abortive revolution of 1919 oh five so
that by the time
Eisenstein came to make the film
Battleship Potemkin was kind of like a
founding story right or a fail you know
it was or at least it wasn't about it
was about an abortive a founding that
would then occur years later right it
was see there was this what did I want
it what it dramatized was it was a
historical fact there was a rebellion by
the by the crew of the battleship
potemkin against its officers
and the the battleship sailed into the
port of Odessa and it's it's it's
mutineers were welcomed by the people
and in the port of Odessa and then the
Tsar angry that his that his Navy and
his naval officers had been mutiny
against sent soldiers to Odessa to
decimate not just the the mutineers but
the population of Odessa and and the
passage so the film was understood in a
way it was a revolutionary document or a
tour or Park or Hornet or an attempt to
sort of create a kind of founding myth
for Russian society right because
everyone watching the film would have
known that the real revolution occurred
all the whatever it was 12 or 13 years
later and and and that this was a kind
of rehearsal and it would have been so
the so that the film would have had a
kind of patriotic aura for for its or
for its audience so the passage I'm
going to show you is that is the is the
famous is the famous passage some I
think David Cook calls this the most
famous montage sequence in the history
of cinema
it was certainly profoundly influential
and as we're watching it I may interrupt
it to say a few things as you're
watching but I'll try not to do too much
interruption what I want you to watch
for especially is not only I will have
to make some commentary but I want you
to as you're as you're watching it among
other things
watch for the way in which the length of
the length of the shots is the time
between shots varies and as the film as
the moment as that as the film begins to
it this passage begins to increase in
intensity and terror the the cuffs
become even briefer right and then watch
also the way in which certain other
strategies of Eisenstein's reinforce
this strategy these montage strategies
for example where the camera is
positioned is it looking up at a
character or is it looking down right
and very different thing if you look up
you would large and you you you miss a
PHY if you look down you humiliate and
minimize right watch how he does that
sort of thing
you
you'll find it I think very very
illuminating and and and and significant
the the the sequence is often seen today
as and I rightly I suppose as deeply
heavy-handed because you're not allowed
when you're looking at this film to sort
of have an alternative view of things
the the film doesn't leave you room
Eisenstein strategies don't leave you
room for independent judgment you're
immersed in a in a in a spectacle so
emotional and so wrenching that that
that you don't have time to sort of sit
back and think and come to conclusion
and one can say that this is one of the
great differences between montage
directors and Me's onsen directors not
an accident that most horror movies all
horror movies really are a form of
montage right because your your feelings
are being manipulated you're not you're
you're not supposed to be allowed to sit
back and say how ridiculously
implausible these events are if that
happened it would spoil the film right
we'll come back to these things so here
is the Odessa steps sequence from
battleship potemkin
these are the odessans welcoming the
mutineers one of the things that
Eisenstein was fond of was what a of
montage that was based on two principles
one he called T podge typisch typ a GE
and what he meant by keep ours was the
idea that they were ethnic very racist
in a way that there were ethnic and
social types that could be recognized
visually so he would he would type his
so he felt if I show you this face
you'll know he's a working-class
character if I show you if I show you a
woman with a parasol you'll know that
she belongs to the upper classes and in
fact he's probably right about that
here are the Czar's forces come to
punish the mutineers and the city of
Odessa so the soldiers are on top and
they're forcing people down the steps
and they are presumably shooting them
kristan freeze it for a second
I don't want to distract you by talking
while it's running so let me interrupt
it for a second and say something else
about the way the film works one of the
things Eisenstein understood was and
it's actually a brilliant discovery he
realized that he could create through
his strategies of especially of dramatic
editing he could create a situation in
which the actual time of the experience
that you're watching was not real time
but was what might be called emotional
time that is to say what's happening
here is to it's probably in the film
taking longer than it took in reality
because in moments of horror the horror
is extended and watch how those kinds of
rhythms operate in the film okay
seems like a naive hope
freeze it again Christie what one other
quick observation I mean is I hope you
recognize how artful this is even if
you're not moved in the way the original
audiences would have been I think
contemporary audiences often feel it's
too heavy-handed they they resent they
resist the extent to which the film is
manipulating them but think back to the
earliest days of film what an
unbelievable shocking incredibly
exciting experience it must have been
for early film goers to have an
experience that certainly for the
Russian audience but I think for every
audience that was so intense and so
emotionally powerful so full of fear and
violence that can be evoked by really by
the rhythms of the editing by the music
by how close did you I hope you noticed
the way he mixes in close-ups in
incredibly powerful ways trying to
create certain effects again you're not
given a choice about how to feel about
this do you Candice it you can descend
from it by withdrawing your interest but
you can't say oh I really love those
soldiers who were doing in the shooting
let's make a case for them you're not
allowed to film won't allow you to do
that will it and that's in that sense
it's manipulating you but it's telling a
it's telling us a story about the
creation of a revolutionary society well
finally what remember I said that
there's this question about emotional
about emotional time as against real
time think how long this has been going
on you think that this Massacre is over
right
but in fact it's only half over as
you'll see there's going to be a moment
when horse horse mounted Cossacks
horsemen show up at the bottom of the
steps and get them in a pincher
I don't think this soundtrack is the
original soundtrack it's very good
though as you this is a brilliant moment
I don't know whether we can attribute
this time
Eisenstein or not whether it's suddenly
the music stops
there should be sound now made something
wrong with our print
at least until you saw this because some
of you may recognize this moment as as
something that's been copied in recent
American movies a scene that a kind of
illusion or a reference to the sea
the moment I wanted you to think about
is this baby carriage
ok thanks Kristen blood in the
eyeglasses can you think of a movie in
which you've seen that recently maybe
not that recently it's actually an
ancient film now by by your standards of
Emma how about the Godfather there's a
wonderful scene in The Godfather where a
guy looks up from a from a massage table
and he's shot through the eyeglasses
very memorable moment it's surely an
allusion to this moon but how about the
carriage going down there have been
several films that actually recreate
that moon but the one I'm thinking of is
I wait who is it yes from The
Untouchables Britta but who's the
director do you remember yes Brian De
Palma's film The Untouchables has a
moment just like that and De Palma of
course is a kind of historian of movies
virtually every scene in the De Palma
film is a reference or an allusion to an
earlier film and part of the importance
of Battleship Potemkin is that it is
still a fruitful and fructifying source
of imagery for contemporary filmmakers
so let me conclude then by simply
reminding you that as Cooke suggests in
his book this is the single most
influential montage sequence in cinema
history and that it's a wonderful
instance for us I think of the way in
which film in a different kind of
culture in an authoritarian culture in a
revolutionary culture full of moral
fervor would be conceived both as an
apparatus as a social as as an engine of
social transformation by a society that
controlled film in a way very
fundamentally different from the way in
which film developed let's say in the
United States we will continue these
arguments and I hope complicate them
this evening
you